[Applause]
it was always set to be the most pivotal
of contests Pennsylvania and it didn't
disappoint the senate race that could
decide the country's Direction in the
Keystone State and the U.S networks were
calling it for the Democrats
women won tonight women won tonight well
the celebration here for John fetterman
is reflective of a remarkable turnaround
voters here in Pennsylvania chose the
local lifelong politician over the Trump
endorsed TV personality and political
novice mementos
I never expected that we were going to
turn these red counties blue but we did
what we needed to do
and we had that conversation Donald
Trump had tried to make this night all
about him his Republican party his
candidates his vision but it's been a
tougher sell than he the polls or even
the Democrats expected
just after 10 pm at his Resort in
Florida the former president had felt
confident enough to take to the podium
I'd like to welcome the fake news media
which is back there
and with his own mid evening rundown of
Republican successes so as of this
moment
and we have some out there we are
80 wins and three losses is that good
and to the extent that Trump endorsed
candidates did well he will claim credit
but this was not the Red Wave the polls
had suggested and so watch now will
Trump's successful candidates remain
loyal or will they pivot to other
emerging Republican presidential
candidates like this man Ron DeSantis
re-elected Florida Governor overnight
significantly he won in Miami too
with a wave of Hispanic voters this was
his win not trumps
[Applause]
Sona the woman for governor who likes
the tag Trump in address was looking
anxious former TV anchor and election
denier Carrie Lake was using the
isolated issues with voting machines
here to raise questions it was 2020 deja
vu
it had a big day today and don't let
those cheaters and Crooks think anything
different don't let them doubt don't let
them put doubt in you but remember again
Governor races don't impact the power in
Washington or the direction of the
nation it's the Senate and the house
that counts
the only sign of President Biden
overnight in a photo a tweet he'd spent
the night calling successful Democratic
candidates he would have made more calls
than he thought he was going to
was this his night well it's certainly
looking like his party had better
results than history and the polls both
suggested Mark Stone Sky News in
Pennsylvania